You might not have chosen all these answers, which is totally okay. I think all
of these are great, and here's why. We know successful students make mistakes.
More importantly successful students learn from their mistakes. In this course
even if you don't get a problem right on the first time, you should definitely
try again. If you try the problem again, you're likely to get the correct
answer. &gt;&gt; Then, you can also go back and write yourself a note to remember what
went wrong. The thing that I want to emphasize, is that mistakes are okay. You
might even find some mistakes that we made while making the videos. While we try
to bring you the best material, we aren't perfect. In the first unit, you'll
even see my own handwriting and my drawings improve. I made a ton of mistakes
while making these videos, but for me, the most important part was to reflect
and learn from those mistakes. To be successful in this course, we also
recommend you take notes while watching the videos. These notes can be helpful
for you to solve practice problems, and also help you review content later. It's
a great idea to break up your notes into individual lessons. That way, you can
remember what you learned from each video segment. Third, research tell us that
the most learning occurs while working in groups. Students don't succeed just by
working harder or studying longer. They do better by talking about that. By
discussing it, by practicing it, and teaching others. Usually from lecture, you
only remember 5% of what you hear. From reading, you only remember 10%. Audio
and visual 20, and demonstrations 30%. These are considered to be passive ways
of learning because they don't rely on much from you to, well, learn. When you
participate on the forms, or complete practice problems after videos, you're
becoming an active learner. These are the best things you can do throughout the
course to help yourself learn. And if you're really mastered something, that
means you can teach anyone. That's the best. Fina lly, if you're half listening
or losing focus, just stop. Take a break and come back and try again. You want
to avoid guessing through the quizzes or trying to rush through the material.
One thing we know about learning is that there's an actual physical need for
time to process new material. So give each question your full attention and your
thoughts. Congratulations on completing your first question. We hope you have a
better idea about how to succeed in this course. When you're ready, come join us
in visualize algebra.